hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm today we're going to
be going over one of my favourite traps
it's the Bobby Fischer trap Bobby
Fischer probably one of my favorite
players of all time to study has so much
teachers has taught me so much not
personally but as far as his games and
his technique and the strategies that he
used on the chess board has really made
me the chess player that I am today so
hopefully you guys enjoy this trap as
much as I do
starts out with pawn to e4 yes Bobby
Fischer was not opposed to opening the
game up nowadays you typically just see
pawn to d4 players are a little more
boring these days in my opinion back in
the day Bobby Fischer didn't mind mixing
it up but pawn to e4 and then black
played pawn to c5 obviously this is this
Sicilian offense probably one of the the
best scoring defenses that black can
play here why it's gonna continue with
Knight to f3 simple development move
trying to control the center with his
minor pieces typically you want to bring
your Knights out before bishops
obviously that's exactly what Bobby
Fischer does then Black's gonna play
Knight to c6 again simple development
move at the same time this is the
accelerated dragon for anyone that's too
familiar with all the different
variations of the Sicilian this is
getting ready for the accelerated dragon
from here Bobby Fischer plays d4 typical
both the pawns are going to exchange off
the board and the knight captures on d4
now from here black continues with the
accelerated dragon and the pawns gonna
come to g6 and they the typical dragon
the pawn first comes to d6 and then
later on it comes to d5 but in the
accelerated dragon that the pawn first
comes to g6 the bishop is being kidded
on the kingside and then later on black
will look to thrust forward with a pawn
to d5 trying to save himself that extra
move so if anyone's sitting there not
too familiar with the accelerated dragon
that that's kind of the quick version of
how it differs from the regular dragon
and the Sicilian offense but from white
from here why it's gonna play Knight to
c3 again simple development move trying
to control the center of the board and
blacks in a play Bishop to g7 again
Theodotus Bishop getting ready to
develop his other minor pieces and get
his King to safety play continues with
Bishop to e3 again
simple development move from white here
getting as minor pieces involved into
the game both the Knights are out so the
bishops can start to come out as well
now the Knights gonna come out to f6 for
black again simple development move at
the same time getting ready to castle on
the kingside from white the bishops down
gonna come to c4 again the LightSquared
bishop is a little bit more powerful at
the beginning of the game because it
can't attack this f7 Square which is a
huge weakness for black early on into
the game from here black is gonna castle
on the King side again King side safety
is a huge factor early on into the game
and then Bobby Fischer plays Bishop to
b3 now if anyone's really studied Bobby
Fischer a lot Bobby Fischer absolutely
loves this move he really loves to bring
his bishop to the b3 square and just eye
down on this f7 squared of the entire
game and just put tons and tons of
pressure on his opponents personally
I've started to try to do this more and
more and just find that it's really hard
for your opponent anytime you can have
more than one weakness for your opponent
it's really hard for them to kind of
play against all those and so Bobby
Fischer just likes to hang out with his
Bishop on b3 and just completely eye
down on this f7 squared the entire game
so that's kind of what he does this is a
typical move nothing crazy out of the
ordinary but at the same time this sets
up a trap and the trap is simple it's
basically luring the knight on c6 to
come to c5 and you'll see this a lot of
times especially the higher up you play
since most players do favor bishops
especially in this game it is an open
game right now but early on in the game
you typically favor bishops overnights
and so a lot of times you'll see the
knight come to a5 because he's really
looking blacks looking to trade off
pieces here he's looking to trade off
this light square bishop for him from
white for his dark squared bishop or
excuse me his dark squared night here on
a5 but Bobby Fischer has different plans
and in the set the trap is already set
up after the knight comes to a5 he kind
of just sets himself in this this trap
the pawns gonna come to e5 and it
attacks this night here on f6 and
there's really
no good place for the night to come the
best move would actually be if the night
comes and captures on b3 then the
exchange could look something like this
the ponds gonna take you're on f6 the
night can come down and capture on a1
again we're just taking as much material
as possible the ponds now gonna come to
g7 the night is already trapped so he
may as well take as much material as he
can he takes on c2 the pawn and then the
night captured and the pawn is captured
now keep in mind white probably has a
better game in the situation
it's kind of kind of tough to tell but
as far as development obviously he's
dominating black in this regard the
darks for bishops are excuse me the
lights for a bishop for blacks not doing
anything all the pawns pretty much not
moved and white pretty much has all his
pieces developed so he does have a
little advantage here but it's very hard
for black to play this in this position
even if he does it's still gonna be good
for white but instead he really has to
find the square for his knight
so let's look at his options obviously
if he brings his knight to h5 this is
probably one of the most passive squares
on the board Knights on the a and the H
file typically is not where you want to
put them if you've ever heard the same
knights on the rim are dim that's kind
of really not what you want here at the
same time if white really wanted to he
could bring his pawn here to g4 he's
pretty much gonna win this Knight here
obviously this knight cannot come to g4
the queen is attacking it here from d1
at the same time if he brings it to d5
it is gonna be captured right away by
this Knight here on C 3 so logical move
is to bring the knight back to e8 you'll
see this a lot of times and a lot of
different openings from black obviously
once you bring your Night Out you castle
on the Kings side and then you go ahead
and bring your knight back to e 8 again
a lot of times black in these scenarios
as far as the accelerator Dragon and the
dragon you like to kind of stay back and
then attack later on kind of see what
your opponent's going to do but as we
can see here e8 is actually going to be
a very big mistake here because White
has a nice little sacrifice with Bishop
to f7 this is just devastating for
lack for a couple of reasons first of
all let's say he captures with his King
here which probably is the worst move
but at the same time I mean there's
really no great move from here white can
play Knight to e6 and this is a
devastating move because this Queen here
on d8 is going to be captured obviously
we can already see now why this trap is
so good at the same time not only is
this Queen going to be captured but this
king is no longer defended he no longer
has this pawn here on f7 anytime your
king is being cut out with the bishop
here on g7 if you lose a pawn it just
becomes that much weaker so anytime
you're feeling kiddo to do with being
kattiline your bishop you always want to
make sure that you have all your pawns
in this case since he's already lost one
pawn and his Kings out that's just not
safe at all so in this case as we can
see even if he does capture right here
then the Queen can come in and capture
on d8 now also keep in mind he could
capture with his rook which is probably
the best move if he does have an option
here because again he doesn't really
want to expose his King if he doesn't
have to you right away
but from here the same thing the knight
can come to e6 this Queen here is gonna
be lost is you okay we can see you can't
come to c7 he'll be captured by the
knight and he can't come to b6 he'll be
captured captured by the bishop best
move really he can come to c7 if he
wants to and then after the knight
captures then the knight can recapture
here and why it's gonna be up a ton of
material but again there's really no
good moves because he has fallen into a
trap so always keep this in mind it
looks like it's a good idea to kind of
bring this Knight back to e8 but it's
actually not after he brings the knight
back to scuse me after he brings his
knight back to e8 then Y can simply come
in sacrifices Bishop on f7 which again
this f7 squares a huge weakness for
black early on and after either these
takes the rook or the king then the
Knights just gonna come here to e6 just
a devastating move right here you can
really see there's a problem with all
these pawns
none of them being moved up and at the
same time all these pieces on the back
range just kind of minimizing all the
different squares that
all these pieces can come too especially
the Queen in this case so this is the
Bobby Fischer attack he used it over and
over again it's pretty sad that people
kept falling for it I've used it a few
times it's awesome the great thing about
it is even if they don't fall for it if
even if they don't bring their Knight to
a5 you still have a fantastic game
anytime you can set your you're opening
up your board up like Bobby Fischer does
you're pretty much gonna give yourself a
good opportunity to win the game so
hopefully you guys enjoyed this video if
you have any questions feel free to
leave a comment and I will see you guys
in the next video thanks for watching